this is cam Jordan the New Orleans
Saints there's no introduction
three-time pro-bowler first-team all-pro
this past season yeah it sounds like
good breakfast yeah and full time NFL
Network employee in Minneapolis damn how
many how many segments do you do over
how many days in Minneapolis I think I
saw you Saturday and I said you are now
a full-time employee you are mr. media I
was looking for my royalty checks but I
didn't get any so I can't I can't be all
that but I do appreciate you having me
on taking shape for a richer period I
was looking to talk about the 40
situation now it's never really improved
sub 540 right and then you know you're
here so we can talk about your Ford
might what what hey can you pull up off
my Instagram Chris from from at the
network huh at the network for the run
rich run thing which is great to benefit
st. Jude's and it's awesome it's a great
tradition now they set up a 40 thing
behind our stage and everyone runs it
and they film it no they do films my
fault a couple of years ago I pulled a
hammie on my way to the combine flew to
Indy with the ice pack on my leg on the
plane this time I didn't want to push it
but I did in jeans and the tie I'm older
than you how old are you 28 33 and my
dad's 50 something I'm sure showed your
dad dad where'd your old man get a 49er
if we had your old man at 53 can run a
sub 50 what is he now 56 57 yeah I'm
thinking he can run a 44 before 9 ater
but yeah pretty sure that's a big by
sense you know next I'll be home next
week so it's a challenge next February
that's your dad's name Steve 13 year
info tied in yes we will talk about it
Viking legend Steve Jordan yes I I just
thought of that thanks I need more
coffee what was my time I don't know
there's this a bad picture of you kind
of grunting yeah but did I do my time on
the bottom of that no you just said that
you escaped the 40 uninjured
all right so just something yeah we'll
just leave it on time my agent I should
be flagged for 15 for forgetting the
whole Steve Jordan thank you see it's
alright well now that now that we're
talking flags let's get to some of these
rule changes I want to talk about the
Saints in a little bit but you're gonna
stick around for a minute too
let's talk about the stuff that went
down this week at the league meeting now
they're calling it targeting it's not a
targeting rule in any way shape or form
the NFL doesn't want you to call the
targeting rule what Roger Goodell said
two days ago is they're trying to take
the helmet out of the game used as in
essence a weapon and they want to get
the helmet I already see the look on
your face back to being two-hand touch
what a protective device a safety device
I sense some doubt from you um yeah I
mean I can completely understand that a
helmet is supposed to protect a head
I'm not saying he's never played
football or anything or anybody who
makes some of these rules
oh yeah it's competitive super
competitive that's what you call the
pinnacle of football then all right cool
so when you talk about you know two
athletes going at full speed and now
taking out the helmet altogether I don't
know
yeah we'll see how that works I think
it's one thing to write it it's another
thing to truly see how it's being
officiated like it we saw on the screen
there the Danny Trevathan hit right
right took out Davante Adams do we agree
that should have been flagged and he
should have been kicked out and he
should have been penalized we talked
about that play we just while I was a
killer got played before that yeah I
mean that one none of them is a Thursday
night he lowered his helmet into Davante
Adams here we could play it again yeah
I'll take that contact that is a penalty
now we don't know what it's gonna be if
you're gonna gang tackle management you
know he clearly wasn't targeting and in
terms of even even this one you've got a
quarterback ducking his head I don't
know if that I don't know if that's what
we call targeting what about this one on
the screen right there he's following
that like I said he's falling in real
time it's a lot faster than what it
seems
it's Travis Kelce by the way right was
on the radio getting hit down as he's
falling you know you
see the defender trying to hit lead with
the shoulder and heads collide the fact
that they are willing cam Jordan to use
replay right like Goodell said on
Tuesday Tuesday Wednesday I'm sorry that
the coaches were adamant hey number one
they supported it B I said a number one
B number two they want a replay element
to it make sure they get it at the right
call
I mean think about that the replay is
probably key in that and that factor
being able to actually slow it down look
at it and you know the only thing I
could say is like hey why not you why
not just let the player and see what see
what he was he was aiming at too you
know at this point just make a
convention of it for every hit yeah I
don't know like I said I'm hard pressed
as a defender if I'm coming out the
stack so [ __ ] if I'm off the line and I
got to plant my foot and I'm taking off
toys like a wide receiver coming off
with a little bubble screen and you know
as wide receivers do they sort of duck
before contact that's not really on me
but again but here's what it also does
because it's not just the tackler right
any player anywhere on the field of the
22
so it also penalize --is the guy the
blindsides and ear holes you right like
so like the Juju's chester juju smith
sister or whoever yeah yeah Vaughn tez
hit I just you know I fear for juju next
season you know eventually Vaughn has a
comeback eventually yeah he's suspended
at the start of every year it is truly a
tradition unlike any of oh yeah I got I
got nothing on that one but that being
said you know they've got to play them
again eventually well here's my point
about about the rule I think we're all
for player safety we agree on that sure
and anyway to make the game easier I'm
sorry not easier safer safer and after
seeing what happened to Ryan shazier
last year for sure I I think I know that
a lot of people step back and said all
right we've been serious in the past we
need to maintain being serious about
finding ways to make this make the game
safer to make it all agree on that to
make this physical contact yes
safer to make this fight to make for it
in sport right that's what it's based
off of his collisions go back five years
ago with what they called the battering
ram or the running back rule lures hands
lower your head as a running back okay
now that lasted for like 10 games
technically that rule didn't apply only
to running backs it applied to anyone
right okay so this is just what we
called it the running back rule because
we wanted to simplify this like we'd
call this now the targeting rule even
though it really isn't it's not like the
college rule that running back rule I
mean it was ripped by anyone who's ever
carried a football anywhere at any time
for sure and it really wasn't applied as
as people feared it would be applied it
only got flagged on the most egregious
of plays I'm curious to see how this one
truly does get applied I'll tell what
you circle that Ravens and bears game
for the Hall of Fame game but it always
gets a huge number because it's the
first game back I am fascinated to see
how that game is officiated and how all
65 in the preseason are officiated for
sure if that's they need anything with
an indication of how it will be treated
for the season for sure you know III had
hope that when it comes to especially
this targeting rule can lead to ejecting
football players that again hopefully
this replay system really helps us out
well they're gonna eject guys now from
New York they say that that was also
passed this week right they have the
ability so for example here's Gronkowski
in the AFC Championship game getting hit
by Barry Church hmm they could shoulders
yeah and I agree but again the rule is
head or neck area right anything
anything head or neck area but the
Gronkowski play against today Thea's
white where he came back off the top
rope with the atomic oh yeah the atomic
elbow yeah could have and would have
been ejected from New York on that most
likely should have and should have been
exactly that was a no-brainer he lost
his he lost his temper for a second
mm-hmm how would you make the game safer
I mean
you know Kenyon what how would you you
know going in you know you know going in
a football that you know you're you're
risking your physical health there in
terms of bodies colliding you know as
safe as you'd like to make it I'm gonna
say that's above my pay grade for sure
and really above my temperament when you
talk about I know what I do as a
defender I know what offensive lineman
likes to do what a quarterback likes to
do it's hard to put this in the
parameters of a targeting rule simply
because you know when I hit a
quarterback at or the quarterback
normally shrugs down and whether I'm
targeting his his you know shoulder or
whether I'm targeting his breast plate
if he if say I'm going to go hit a Matt
Ryan Matt Ryan shrinks down and now I'll
sudden my helmets and his helmets
parameters his you know he's bracing for
exactly he's bracing for impact and
because of him bracing now we were
quote-unquote colliding and I get ejects
from game I'm probably gonna be hot for
a long time I probably be talking this
for you know years to come cam Jordan
joins us here three-time Pro Bowler from
the New Orleans Saints son of the great
Vikings tight end Steve Jordan have you
talked to dad about these rules no not
at all um last week or so um you know my
older brother just had his like 31st
birthday he's getting old happy birth
Jesus yesterday Jesus loves my brother
your brother's name is Jesus Hazel's
know Joffrey just turned 31 awesome but
yeah when you talk about you know me and
my dad we'll be talking about it I had
to first understand these rules and so
we'll probably go from there cuz I don't
fully understand well I think your dad
I'm going to assume it's probably happy
as we saw you and you're down on the
screen there about the new catch rule
those whose guy that caught passes for a
living which seems like it seems like
that we have kind of got defines you a
little bit of common sense with the cats
rule hmm
you think yeah you know breaking the
plane is a touchdown was it making a
football move as the third step in the
process but it's right in other words so
Jesse James reaching over right that's
the football move you don't have to
worry about the ball hittin the ground
words he reached over right exactly so
again I'm sure all offensive players are
excited about that one I've talked to
defensive guys who actually like it
because they think it's gonna lead to
more fumbles is that so what was like so
for example this wasn't a catch and I
granted it's over the goal line it's a
little bit different but if this were in
the middle of the field where last year
it would have been he didn't survive
going to the ground right now it's a
catch he's reaching for the gold not
reach he's reaching for this dipper to
get that ball comes out no it's on play
now it's in play huh yeah that could be
a advantageous towards us but at the
same time you got to deal with you got
to deal with these rules as they come
and you know that's fun as much as you
know I'd like to say I have my own
opinion on all these rules they're gonna
be they're clearly gonna be applied to
the game and we have to be able to
evolve and adjust to them I think the
biggest issue that one is how quickly
we're gonna get whistles right like
middle the field he's reaching right
he's reaching this again I think it's
gonna lead up to preseason I think
that's sort of a good is going to set a
tone for what's gonna happen regular
season alright for those who don't know
the new catch rule is as such you need
to do three things need to have the ball
obviously possession you need to have
the two feet down and then you need to
do a third thing which used to be called
a football act they they've kind of
taken that language out but it's do
anything it's reach for the sticks reach
for the goal line take another step do
anything like that and then they're
gonna say it's a catch what they
basically did is they took the going to
the ground and controlling it through
the ground no out of it right which
which kind of makes more sense alright I
want to talk about the Saints mmm
obviously would you allow us to go back
to that day in Minnesota coming up into
the oh my gosh just for oh yes for a
second fine fine I want to ask you what
I throw off this this this coffee mug
off the table don't I don't hold it
against me all right good coming up next
cam Jordan of the Saints throws a coffee
mug at me I set off the table off the
table off the table coffee mug yeah and
they say at this day and age I can't you
know you can't direct it anybody it was
just off the table guy
sure I kind of believe him tamp sticking
around for 15 more minutes want to ask
him about what it would have been like
to play within da mic and Suez well
granted he's coming here to LA that's
not gonna happen
stick with us Andrew Siciliano sitting
in for rich on the Rich Eisen show now
right TV only here eyes an extra they
call the cam Jordan the Saints is here
I'm Andrew Siciliano Brockman you have a
photo if you remember saw you at NFL
Honors you were lookin DAP in a velvet
jacket I was wearing velvet also who
complimented me we saw Alvin Camaro
later on he was wearing velvet had to
take a photo of the velvet boys
hey no doubt smooth is velvet on and off
the field
smooth Velvets bet helmets back okay
what is that you're wearing there little
jacket situation um you know I thought
it would when will my db4 is here I
think it looks good it's it's sparkle it
pops on the TV as well we're talking
here during the commercial how many
legacy families like yourself and your
dad Steve so there's the Matthews right
there's the Mannings right there's a
long so long saab viously I even you
know I even went out and said the birds
Jairus Byrd is dead Perry means okay
Herman they're in Baltimore is that
Brett Perriman long time wide receiver
as well what else we got here Brockman
the engrams
yes the atoms as well Jamal Adams dad
George played okay there we go for the
Giants I'm just thinking New York there
this is kind of like is there a family
feud episode here I'm just saying
whew 10 chili I mean if there is I'm
probably you know the Jordans are
probably taking that one home you don't
you know would you go coaching at the
Gruden's as well oh no I was gonna go
coaching cuz you know coaching you know
they haven't done them done play yeah
they haven't done one play now Jay
Gruden heck of an Arena League
quarterback
are we counting are we counting brothers
too cuz we got the Kelsey's the Kelsey's
your father's legacy
the lots like you know a nice when when
my son tank takes a field in you know
Cubs tank 2 so in 19 years
Jordan tank Jordan huh you know how hard
had a fight for that that's government
by the way government middle but
government okay so tanks is real yeah if
he ever has to have like a real job to
go by his first name not here for that
what's tank gonna play hopefully yes I'm
trying to make him actually a best ball
player but he's only six six you know
Denny is the frame just holes like you
know 250-260
one of the greatest football legacy
families in the history of the National
Football League
this is camp Jordan here three-time Pro
Bowler and along with your dad you have
how many uh we have nine nine say f3
okay so that's get six Steve out there
with the Matthews none you belongs
you're not done yet one of these days
you will surpass dead on the way likely
to Canton Ohio now I hate to bring this
up but we promised we talked about it
you also threatened to potentially throw
that mug maybe not at me we stated we
stated promise we don't have to know
okay
but let's get it out of the way all
right so I think it's okay to hold
things in I know it eats you up inside
but I also think it drives you how long
if ever will it take for you to get over
the way the NFC divisional round ended
in Minnesota um next playoffs this this
upcoming playoffs you mean after you
know we're in the Superbowl but it's
Indiana
yeah but till then I'm just gonna hold
that in a very near and dear place in my
heart how is Marcus Williams always
working out forever getting better
looking to I can't even say repent
looking to have a better season than he
did his rookie season which was a very
good season pretty solid season yeah um
you know I in my mind he had one of the
better rookie showing outs and you're
gonna have I mean the only one probably
beats it is a K and Marshawn Lattimore
maybe you know the Trey white you guys
had a phenomenal work there was a strong
rookie class this year and he's he's
what a tough I probably put him top five
do you think he was afraid of getting
flagged for hit and when he was in the
air for sure you can see I mean he just
arrived a little bit too early
and you know after looking at the tape
after reviewing everything at this
product this point probably uh no less
than 100 or 200 times you know you can
only put it on I'd like to say in that
clip had I've been able to recreate some
Detroit Lions off of the tackle until
quarterback madness mmm-hmm we wouldn't
even have to face that play so I'm gonna
put it on myself before I put it on any
of my teammates interesting has has as
Marcus gotten grief in New Orleans
because fans can be mean sometimes um
you know what anything that happened
after that game there's going to be
emotional waves but as strong as
Marcus's mentally he's able able to
weather anything beyond that and in
terms of our our fan base is so loyal
anything beyond you know let's give it a
week um they weren't really true who
they have fans anyways good I here this
is camp Jordan of the Saints three-time
pro-bowler Saints looking to go further
obviously this coming season then the
divisional round the the offseason feels
different this year for you guys from my
perspective in years past the last
couple of years there's always been that
well maybe Shawn's leaving whistle
didn't happen right wasn't that a
beginning of the year to let you know oh
it always it always happened guys slowly
seven years later of we know I'm not
really worried about it but doesn't it
feel different that after all those
rookies did do well after it did come
together after a slow start after you
went where you went in the playoffs and
you coulda woulda shoulda won that game
that this year feels like all right
let's get drew back here there is no
discussion no matter how late it went
right like we are in we are staying
together and then we're going for it
next year no doubt and sort of creating
like a reunion tour as well um you know
with the with us reuniting with you know
Patrick Robinson but now Benjamin Watson
Benjamin yes Benjamin Watson German
Bushrod
you know I think there's a lot of guys
that were veterans on the team and know
know how to win being brought back into
the locker room so we talk about guys
again like Bushrod who won a Super Bowl
I'd like to say he was low older than I
did so when you have him coming back to
the to the to the facility something's
gonna help Corral our young guys be even
better I know you're not back in the
facility yet but I know Benjamin
Watson's getting there were you before
before Benjamin got signed were you at
all part of the recruiting process for
Jimmy Graham huh huh I want to talk
about how I failed okay
I'm not ready to talk about these
failures because I was like I was like 1
for 4 in recruiting Alex Okafor came
back you know I mean I I'm just shooting
out whether I had any influence or not
really I don't know you know you talk
about you talk about my guy Jimmy Graham
you know that was my my guy when it was
bad part of the Saints did you still my
guy I got nothing but love for him I was
hoping so you know um I don't know what
goes on financially speaking in terms of
contracts and negotiations but clearly
something fell through because you know
I'd like to say he was sort of excited
to come back to reunite with you know
His Airness Drew Brees you know any time
you can have a tight end of that caliber
it becomes special you know I I got had
the pleasure of just haphazardly meeting
up with in down McCain because I was you
know working out on his visit I see air
quotes of those on the radio here quotes
working out we're working out worked out
together I mean you know he just got in
the middle of you know I was like hey
you know with the with the massive
interior presence you know just think
they can't double team both of us
you know what do you say to that and
Donald you can't you can't you know you
gotta focus I don't know you know he
wanted a clearly another massive
presence on that interior line and kudos
to him I failed there - who else at the
GM yeah you know what I feel like I feel
like you know in terms
dear friends I thought I could be maybe
a presence that he'd like to come
towards anyways anyways so was that one
for three but you you did get drew brees
back that was congratulations on that
didn't have any recruiting involvement
was not a tweet not a not a wink not a
hey are you coming back do you think at
all no wait it went all like I mean look
it got to the point where he was allowed
to talk to other teams his legacy of
winning a Super Bowl his his work that
he's done in the city since 2006
mm-hm that's that's 12 years so you want
to go somewhere else to sort of restart
that stop it when you're everyone who
has reached out to Tom Condon who cares
okay yeah who cares
drew said he was coming back in the st.
said he was coming back so whether they
were opening up negotiations for other
teams to come in and talk not I feel
like they had their own special
agreement so I wasn't worried all right
so you know that players
you can't tamper all right I don't
coaches can tamper can they players
can't
how did bad players tamper well for
example when Todd Gurley says hey sure
I'd love to play with Odell that's not
tampering right okay so would you
recruit Odell Beckham coaches can't
tapper right places so we coach or a GM
right like John Dorsey can't confer you
know yes Yotam is going to you know
Dallas code correct come get me if you
can't exactly okay but you can so would
you would you considering your great
success record a couple of weeks ago
would you go after Odell if asked to
recruit um you know I feel like Odell's
from Louisiana
you know it's LSU the home protections
here I'm simply saying you know Adele
knows you know if he wants to come home
we always got a you know this is gonna
be a spot for I don't know if we can
afford him at his going rate but you
know how that again I have no part in
this financial but you know we always
got a home just think Mike Thomas and
Odell together yeah that would be pretty
nasty you know and you know Benjamin
Watson and
you know I'm marking Raavan Camaro and
you know we got so easy we'd have some
some serious firepower not to say we
already don't you do you do and
hopefully going at least one step if not
two steps further next year then you did
last before I let you go and we love
that you came in here and thanks for
sticking around for two segments have to
ask you about your memories the mr.
Benson who we lost a couple of weeks ago
of course um you know it's somewhat
cliched but I think we saw it with his
death is that in New Orleans you don't
just mourn you celebrate the life of
somebody we have lost and that and that
was a celebration for a man who meant so
much as a native son a self-made
billionaire to that community yeah um
you know I had I had some prior
engagements that I just left like that
Wednesday before the the funeral back
home to Arizona so I miss his funeral we
talked about everything that he'd meant
to the city you know I'm not sure what
he did pre-katrina that's not of my
knowledge but post-katrina I mean him in
the city went hand in hand I mean they
pretty much built back up together and
then of course you talk about him being
the owner of the Saints bringing a Super
Bowl to that city with two or three
years after Katrina really helping rally
that the whole city together then of
course you talk about the Benson tower
you talk about everything that he owns
in the city the Pella homes the again
then he purchased purchases the pelicans
kept them there um to keep them there of
course you know they were the Hornets at
the time yeah either way they become the
pelicans and everything that that he's
done for that city I mean his footprint
is probably gonna be there for ever it
is a lasting and a proud legacy and a
legacy that certainly he leaves in good
hands now with his widow Gail his wife
Gail he's taking over the team and
nothing is going to change mrs. B and
hopefully I know you guys are fighting
next season in his memory to take it a
couple of steps further than what we had
in Minnesota this is a future star on on
game day morning but that's that's a
long time down
Road I jokingly referred to earlier as
NFL network scam Jordan we welcome you
back anytime welcome you back here next
time obviously with Rich Eisen right
right on their Rich Eisen show um better
luck recruiting next time you know you
know um you know the next year there's
another there's another chances you know
I'm sure that you know this draft
process coming up hopefully you know I
can't even say who I want to get because
normally I don't have an opinion I just
accepted what it is two years ago I was
like I just assumed we were gonna get my
guy Sheldon rankings and we did so I
appreciate that one after looking at us
you know some of the younger guys coming
through an heir apparent could be made
I'm just simply saying you know you say
at a quarterback hey I just want to
leave it at heir apparent you want to
name the quarterback shelter for
rankings show the records games
listening on the radio
I think I saw Lamar Jackson i I know I
said my guy Sheldon wrinkles came from
Louisville right it wasn't a bad choice
yeah interesting
um so you know I'm not saying that
there's a connection there I'm just not
saying that there wouldn't be in my mind
I don't know damn Jordan future teammate
of one Lamar Jackson thinks they are my
words to the mercedes-benz Superdome
confused there cuz it land of copied us
on that one you know that what are they
there's a lot of money huh that's what
they do why why Atlanta theirs has
chick-fil-a yours does not but yours is
still cool two billion dollar facility
I'm a little jealous but it's cool I
mean we'll play Super Bowl there this up
come here exactly
you'll be there you'll be there in the
regular season as well hey cam thanks
for coming in man
seriously tell Dad I said hi of course
and I did not forget him I appreciate
that
I'm definitely letting no you forget
them and now you're doubting that he
came round us up 540
damn Jordan the Saints everybody
three-time pro-bowler
thank you again sir the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience